ça se passe bien avec des nez de clown
du tout tu parle pas comme ça tu ton
père de neige pas à pas des béni oui oui
et non vous êtes de garde ce soir de
faire ce soir je dîne avec le nouveau
mec de mon ex femme
vous connaîtrez ça bien assez tôt et
ckoi sont une famille morteau à morteau
comme à saucisse c'est marrant tu fais
quoi en fait dans la vie et là je
cherche des idées pour claquer mon blé
est ce que comme je vois plus beaucoup
ça prend du temps et il pratique
toujours le shiatsu connard méconnu plus
quand je suis passé à 5 ans choquée je
pense que tu m'as trompée pendant cinq
ans les jolis minois aller voir des pas
sur une aire d'autoroute la maman dis
pas la renaudié dos de vous parler d'un
sujet très important je pense que vous
devriez vous remettre ensemble
enfin ici ce soir non tu votre mère à
banja dirai pas ce que fait un gosse
années maintenant
et c'est debout j'ai 42 ans je ne sais
pas quel âge aurait dans 10 ans alors si
c'est pour avoir un enfant que plus
vieux que ce soit jean pas l'intérêt
c'est un gosse change de papa benoît
appel et pourquoi non pas toi tu
m'appelles daddy on sature un disque en
anglais
parker est mature et je sais que je suis
pas ta mère mais la violence verbale
c'est pareil que j'avais un site web la
prochaine fois je mettrais directement
une bof
vous êtes tous malades dans cette
famille
qui compte beaucoup
maman elle a trébuché
l'adolescence est un âge difficile la
vieillesse n'est pas génial an plus tôt
sur la perçois je préfère me se poser un
bout de sens qui me fais tu